la tunisie en pleine crise sanitaire
s'enfonce jour après jour dans un
marasme politique sont pressés dans un
dialogue rompu entre le chef de l'état
et son premier ministre tensions entre
députés au sein même de l'assemblée ou
encore portefeuilles ministériels vide à
reportage tunis deux bassins chebbi est
aisée et nasri dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée des représentants du peuple
les députés se font de plus en plus
rares avec un taux d'absentéisme
dépassant les 22 % que l'on soit de la
majorité ou de l'opposition
nombreux sont ceux qui semblent avoir
baissé les bras à l'heure où la tunisie
traverse la pire crise de son histoire
tension sociale inédite blocage
politique sans précédent et profonde
crise économique dans le pays
tous les indicateurs sont au rouge alors
que plusieurs partis et organisations
mettent en garde contre l'explosion de
la situation sociale dans le pays
que l'on soit de droite ou de gauche le
dialogue national semble apparaître
comme le dernier recours pour sortir de
la crise il faut absolument que le
dialogue soit renoué entre les trois
chefs
car dans le cas contraire c'est une
guerre civile qui nous attend contre
conditions et le respect aujourd'hui il
ya des députés qui insultent ouvertement
dans l'hémicycle le président de la
république
comment voulez vous après que le chef de
l'état les reçoivent on demande que ces
derniers présentant exclu ennahda a
toujours été pour le dialogue national
notre parti a toujours demandé à la
classe politique de dialoguer à
commencer par le chef de l'état et le
chef du gouvernement pour préparer le
dialogue national un dialogue sans veto
ni aucune condition que le dialogue
national ne doit être
conforme de celui de 2013 il doit être
un dialogue en vue du partage des
pouvoirs
cela doit être un dialogue structuré et
efficace pour en sortir des solutions
économiques et sociales notre parti a
émis deux conditions à commencer par la
démission du gouvernement mais chichi
qui à nos yeux cristallise tous les
problèmes que rencontre notre pays et
deuxième condition le dialogue doit se
passer sous la tutelle du président de
la république y mourir c'est de rester
au mollet rastane au coeur de cette
crise politique
un des accords existants entre le
président de la république kaïs sayed et
le chef du gouvernement michel mais
chichi en raison du remaniement
ministériel du 16 janvier dernier malgré
l'approbation du parlement
le président sayyed a refusé de
convoquer les nouveaux ministres pour la
prestation de serment constitutionnel au
palais de carthage
estimant qu'elle amendement était
entachée de violations propos rejeter en
bloc par les chichis de son côté le
puissant syndicat de l'union générale
tunisienne du travail est monté au
créneau accusant qu'à essayer de
proposer sa propre feuille de route est
de court-circuiter le dialogue national
une initiative du syndicat appuyé par
une majorité de la classe politique
tunisienne
politaïev iddri cette crise est le
résultat d'un dysfonctionnement interne
de l'appareil politique tunisien rythmé
par des conflits d'intérêts partisans
entre les différents pouvoirs et les
différents partis mais aussi l'ingérence
de plusieurs puissances étrangères
le dialogue national peut être une
solution à beaucoup de problèmes
premièrement il faut revoir le système
électoral deuxièmement il doit y avoir
une reprise du dialogue entre le chef de
l'état
le chef du gouvernement et le président
du parlement
chacun doit connaître son rôle à la
question ce dialogue vous représentez de
la solution finale à cette sortie de
crise il est difficile de répondre par
l'affirmative car ce qui les oppose et
bien supérieur à ce qu'il est lu et
chacun d'entre eux à sa propre feuille
de route
il en va de même pour leurs relations
avec les pays étrangers ce qui ne fait
qu'accentuer la crise on pense notamment
aux nombreux déplacements de monsieur
ghannouchi à ankara pour rencontrer le
président r 2 add ou encore ceux avec
fayez al sa rage le chef du gouvernement
d'union national libyen absence de
leadership gouvernance bloqué
surendettement et chris partisane sc
l'état dans lequel se trouve aujourd'hui
la tunisie dans cette situation des plus
incertaines nombreux sont ceux qui
voient en ce possible dialogue national
la solution miracle alors que dans le
pays les manifestations populaires
s'accentue pour demander une refonte
totale du système politique en place